[Music]
in party crasher news submitted by moist
dryer that doesn't make [ __ ] sense
idiot a typo led a man to join in on a
stranger's bachelor party Oh address
typo what kind of tape like an email
typo yep
invite typo your salsa mat oh they're
saying like I was saying like everyone
no one's welcome you sent the wrong
person so this was B Bobby Brown 13 13
yeah but then this guy probably sent to
Bobby Brown 3 3 3 and then he showed up
shut up so this happen Bobby Brown he's
like oh my gosh I finally had some free
what a party act so this whole thing
that's what I'm saying
Oh [ __ ] statuses human being like I
don't know you would do that no listen
like this what I'm saying I don't know
about is like for some reason this story
rubs me the wrong way and I just it just
annoys me for some reason how does it
rub you the wrong way I'll tell you the
little story Oh tell I want to see if it
rubs me the right way ok so this story
revolves around the fan named will Novak
he's from Arizona okay hey Novak's man
no I like Arizona as Novak's shut the
[ __ ] up it's dirty
you little monkey come on come on
perfectly represents JK news
it's like confetti like we're just not
just all over the place you know the
most professional news source out there
on the Internet today all right so now
what will Novak from Arizona he got this
email he says that it seemed urgent like
one of those emails that you get from a
prince
so initially he thought it was a scam
but then so he just he decided to open
the email
bachelor party that's [ __ ] funny so
he said it's he thought it was from a
prince so he knows that it's gonna be a
scam but he still opened it I'm pretty
sure this is a virus got to open it
right click on the link really I like to
read Nigerian prince scam Nigeria yes so
he opened it and then it was about
Angelo's bachelor party saying that they
were gonna have this ski trip in Vermont
and you know it's an 80s themed
ski trip all right I'm Dino and Angelo
he's doesn't know any Angelo that sounds
so fun already though a ski trip and
you're just a tease I'm in let's go I
could have a mullet and I could have
super colorful like neons I could just
like Dumb and Dumber
oh I was not I was thinking the cool
part of the eighties yeah the dumb and
Dumberer all of their clothes look like
the Neapolitan ice cream yes and that
email I'm talking about like they want
them to respond with the shirt size
because they're gonna have shirts made
out that there's gonna be ski tickets
and then pretty much you're charging
$150 per person for the housing the food
the beer don't cheat yeah that's really
short for a ski trip
that's why cheap yeah so then maybe
there's like a hundred people in a place
that only holds like 20 that's true
because if you go to big B Z even just a
one-day ski lift is like 80 bucks now
holy macaroni
I don't know what the whole hype is you
have to pay for your own Sookie tickets
just to oh the food beer housing I still
cheap yeah anyway so then 100 bucks
should be the beer by itself yeah we try
to take Tycho to go freaking skid around
on that little blue disc beam yeah and
it's very dangerous yeah and we bought
one from Big Five so I take the brown
like a personal one so I found like this
kids play area Big Bear oh cool can I
just go in there and now the part where
all the kids get to used to play now I
have to pay 25 bucks to get in there get
the [ __ ] out of here yeah and I'm like
what up boss no it's free homey that's
what I thought
well they make it a big berry here they
make that path for the slit oh yeah
that's what went off to the other side
where we found just snow on this aren't
you guys doing the whole like tradition
of parking by a hill and then just
that's what we did that's what we did
after this will cracks me up though
he'll buy like a $300 sleeping bag he
never uses but a $25 fee for my child
with them we went to the side of the
street to find some good spots
I'm the good parent here I get tyke up
his shoes is closed his toys like I
bought him the disc 895 garbage can lid
yeah that's [ __ ] play so anyway so
then we'll response to this email it
starts off with all I do not know who
Angelo is I am will Novak who lives in
Arizona
Vermont seems like a very far away for
me to travel for the bachelor party of a
guy I've never met uh that being said
[ __ ] count me in
that's email Angelo Sal's tremendous
Allah you just keep storing in Moore
Doakes and how does it rub you the wrong
way wait so Subban um he ends up
deciding to go or no so that email he
sent it as a joke like he didn't really
think that they're even gonna respond
but then they responded and they were
like you think we're kidding but we're
not
you need to come like we have to have
you come like we need to meet you know
so why people to make yeah they don't
know dangers yes yes serial killer yeah
so then well then they asked to have him
send his like Facebook page kind of bet
they were like we're crazy brew not
stupid
yeah and then they were like we waved
your $150 cost but they think crazy
people don't have facebook pages okay so
then he created this GoFundMe page shoe
fun the 150
find the one no so it turned out to be
seven hundred and fifty dollars at the
flight and like he wants to rent his own
car in case they're crazy
okay and he has a ten month old daughter
and a wife too just like oh you know so
he was like this is not in family budget
a spontaneous trip across the country
his wife's like yeah go ahead
yes that's what he's like he's so
[ __ ] annoying I want him out of here
no friends anyone what a serial this
like you posted this on his social media
profiles and it just went insanely viral
what that's the part that I'm like I'm
like I don't know it's just like
something about it I'm like how much did
he raise
let's look into that too so then wait
wait wait wait wait I'll get to them
well you know so it goes I have to tell
you some more detail okay okay you're
just like you bothers me a little bit
okay okay so we so he ended up raving
four thousand five hundred and twenty
dollars on the GoFundMe Wow yes what
damn people buying four hundred dollars
four thousand that's more than seven
hundred yes she raised 750 within two
hours
Wow so then I don't like this story huh
yeah I'm gonna get crazy he he ended up
getting so when he flew out there to
Vermont he got like the ski tickets
conked he got like we his renter his
rental car upgraded him to a Maserati
because they all knew about this yeah
like it spread liking like so they
probably wanna like use this as a way
for marketing yeah so then they also he
also got a ton of free beer from all
these people that I wanted to donate
beer to the bachelor party he what else
got a new wife and a new 1000
you just kept getting a whole bunch of
things left and right oh he's been doing
like an insane amount of television our
new interviews what an insane that's the
part that I'm just like what for being a
good guy because he wanted to party yeah
as in strangers yeah it could be Vermont
has jack [ __ ] going on
so it's either they interviewed this guy
the country good morning morning America
the championships everyone everything
this man what is Vermont known for
Vermont snow for some good exactly
let's continue maple supporting maple
syrup Vermont wrote people certain old
boarding maple syrup and then I guess
New England lobster Vermont yeah I don't
know I got Manas Lobster yeah but an
outside broadened it to New England wait
does remind you in touch of ocean sure
to land right next to make it really
small make sure there's a Vermont and
New Hampshire ish and then something
like that but ferpa maple syrup is there
serious out there about that Vermont
maple syrup yeah but that ain't the only
place you can walk me on that too is I
mean Canada gasoline or maple shoo cuz
it got so much publicity
well it didn't hurt me that much until I
read his GoFundMe page and someone
commented it under their singing because
this all sounded a little bit familiar
to me I'm like I've heard this story
before I know I have and then in Flavia
huh this has happened month trip go
skiing no so then I read the comment
opportunity and it's from this guy named
Joey he's like man this story brings
back old memories because almost four
years ago I was in and almost the exact
same spot as you and then it has his
GoFundMe page and I read into his story
and I'm like that's the story I read and
if they exactly
same thing where it was like they have
similar names the email somehow got a
little bit switch
he ended up responding yes I'm gonna go
it's across the country - we did it Jake
he knows about it I think so it sounds
so familiar that's what like
encompassing everything I'm just like
this just doesn't feel right so bogus
yeah I don't know maybe it is like a
crazy-ass show did you all know that
so did you investigate what and find out
that it was Shady
no I mean this is me just telling you
everything I've come across oh you're
using your Latina judgement yourself
he's off wanted free beer senses are
telling me this is a scam
you know be funny if one was the other
guy and in the past story well yet by
the way they meant to invite Bill Novak
that's the type of this is Bill that's
Bill this is will well bill [ __ ]
crazy what the 80 themes remember still
look at Bill did yeah they look like
they look they like to wake up and not
know where they're at
yeah so who got [ __ ] in the ass why me
yeah even while they were skiing there
were news outlets they just they were
good they were snowboarding with the
camera falling that must have made like
everybody's day for sure
that is tight okay conspiracy time what
do you think it really was what do you
think
it was it a marketing ploy what do you
think I don't know that was like a
marketing ploy like I just I I just feel
like cuz remember the whole homeless
story with the 20 bucks
better than in tears and yeah something
like feels like it's like we might
unfold some other secrets later I know
what it is what is it good job Maserati
it was a Maserati campaign campaign
Facebook they do need it though because
they used to be considered an extremely
high-end brand and then flip their
marketing to go the other way to make it
more of an accessible luxury SUV bad
moves Maserati so maybe that's what
they're doing I used to like a car
before you were like BMW so anyway so
now
well Novak is saying that the rest of
the money that he raised for that
GoFundMe it's gonna go to Angelo and his
his new wife because they just found out
that they're having the first baby oh
that's nice that's really cool yeah I
mean so he said it's a happy ending
after all
and just like barb they don't see that
$25 fee to go on a little saying they're
doing no absolutely not
it wasn't that honestly it wasn't the
fee it was you have to pay this knows
the house the fee and they'll can you
fill out this form all my forms right
[ __ ] all my mother for me default is
safety for ya you leave up to fill out
forms when you buy a lift ticket but
then I guess cuz its kids you gotta like
write all this [ __ ] down long as I
[ __ ] this man
so you want to write up a piece of paper
for your kid well we're gonna go
endanger his life on our own terms
my friend yeah mud patch over there with
most Dookie that's for you tiger
[Music]